hey guys what's up i'm so excited for
you to watch this interview before we
get into this interview i want to talk
about our sponsor
prime xbt if you're trading bitcoin
you got to be using primex bt not only
do they have global markets
available to anyone but they also have
great execution
low fees and an amazing user interface
the best part about primexpt is that you
can also follow some of the best traders
in the world
you go on you find someone who you think
is smart and you can literally just
follow their trades when they execute
something your portfolio executes the
same
and if you think you're one of the best
traders in the world then you can simply
go on there and have people follow you
and you earn a little extra income by
having those followers
so if you're trading bitcoin anywhere in
the world you got to use primex bt
they've won multiple awards for being
one of the best trading platforms
in crypto you can trade spot markets or
even use margin
so go on over to use primexpt you can go
to the description and click on the link
there
all right let's get into this episode
today i really hope you guys enjoy this
one
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i hope everyone
is doing well i have karen here with me
thank you so much for doing this
thank you for sure let's just jump into
your background we're going to have a
great conversation today about the
federal reserve its role in society and
all the chaos that's been going on in
markets over the last
year or so but um maybe just start with
how you started your career and then
um what you've done over over the last
couple of years
well as anyone watching this can tell i
am what the
people politely call a woman of a
certain age so i
started my career in the in the way back
and i was finishing my phd
in political science at uc berkeley
when i realized much as i really enjoyed
what i was doing and what i was studying
that i didn't want to be an academic
that was back in the day where the uc
berkeley political science department
had 40
uh 45 professors and the one woman who
of course was not a professor was just
an adjunct lecturer and
it became pretty clear to me that that
was not going to be a great way to go
so um a variety of just
complete coincidences i got offered a
job to be the
the first and only political scientist
because i was getting my phd in
poli-sci at bank of america and that's
how i got into finance
i knew nothing about banking uh
but um i got quickly involved by
the by the uh my boss and by the bank
and very interesting financial policy
questions
at the time into what was congress and
the administration and the bank
regulators doing
and then i got moved to washington and
i've stayed here ever since
doing pretty much the same thing i
started my own company
in 1985 when the then chief executive
officer of the bank said he didn't feel
good about making a young woman a senior
vice president uh damn that's happening
all over again just like academia so i
thought maybe i
you know i was 32 at the time at that
i'll try starting my own company because
if i can make it go
now is the time to try it and i did and
it's been great ever since
you have this amazing story um and
you're just a wealth of knowledge so i
want to start with
the most important question uh which is
what the hell
is the federal reserve's role in the
economy and in
uh the american system i think that
everyone knows obviously uh
the federal reserve exists they hear
people talking about it all the time
uh there's a smaller group of people
that understand maybe it's not so
federal
uh maybe there's not so many reserves
but how do you describe what the federal
reserve's
role in the economy is well i call my
new book
engine of inequality the fed and the
future of wealth in america
engine because the fed does have an
enormous role powering or reversing
inequality economic inequality in
america
and the reason for that is fundamental
to what
central banks like the federal reserve
do
no agency in the united states drives
money as powerfully as a central bank
that's what
central banks do it's called monetary
policy
and money is really the fuel of economic
inequality
as economic inequality is determined by
who has what percentage of income who
has much
what in percentage of wealth and the fed
is critical to that
it sets interest rates it holds a huge
portfolio
it intervenes in the financial markets
and it writes a lot of rules
as well as it actually it's very
important it operates the payment system
and then determines who has access to
the plumbing
to the rails on which the financial
system operates
so it's hugely important even if it's
often invisible
and so when you think about um kind of
the fed's role and i love what you
call uh the engine of uh wealth
inequality
um i think a lot of people don't
understand uh how that works
right and so when you look at uh the
structure of a market
maybe walk us through how wealth
inequality is driven
from monetary policy so just forget the
united states for a second just anywhere
in the world how monetary policy and
wealth and equality actually
interact with each other
if nations started as
equal then the central banks wouldn't
have
that much of a role because if each of
us had
we might not have the same amount of
money but if we had our wealth
distributed in the same kind of assets
and funded those with pretty much the
same amount of debt
then central bank policy would move
neutrally
through the economy so think about it
this way
if we all had 10 of our wealth
in the stock market whether or not that
10
of the wealth was 10 million dollars or
ten thousand dollars
every time the market goes up we would
be
proportionately this richer it would be
an
equitable distribution
but that's not the way it works in the
united states
now people have what wealth they have
in different assets wealthy people have
by the majority of their assets in the
financial markets in stocks and bonds
middle-class
people have the majority of their wealth
in their home prices even though often
that's very highly leveraged they don't
actually own much of their house because
they've got a big mortgage the amount of
equity they have in their houses is
relatively small
and low and moderate income people don't
own stocks
don't have equities often don't even
have little bits of 401ks
and if they own a home they're often in
even more
debt and most of them are renters often
also saddled with lots of student debt
so you see that
wealth isn't equally distributed in
terms of where we get it
and so when the fed supports financial
markets and as it has since
2010 the fed has taken numerous actions
to ensure that the financial markets
particularly the stock market just go
up up up up up and then it's taken other
actions that make it essentially
impossible to save by putting
your money in a bank wealth ends up
very inequitably distributed because
rich people
had a lot of stock and now they've got a
lot more value in that stock
and middle class moderate and low income
people
had very little stock a whole lot of
debt
and they can't even save because the
money in the bank as i said
in terms of inflation-adjusted rates you
lose money
when rates are as low as they are right
now even with little bits of only a
little bit of inflation
the money you put in the bank is worth
less a year from now
inflation is is higher than interest
rates
and that's a recipe for real inequality
and i think we are seeing that play out
in a major major way one of the things
that i continue to tell people
uh is essentially the government uh
whether they're trying to or not
is playing king maker and determining
who is wealthy and who is not
uh and it's a feature of the system it's
not a bug
right this is not something where uh oh
no we're doing something wrong the
system is working as it is designed
and so what that ultimately leads to is
a lack of financial education right many
of the people you just described
they don't understand how the dollar
works they don't understand how
inflation works and therefore they end
up
saving because that's what their parents
or somebody told them to do
but in reality what they should be doing
is after they've put away a little bit
of money for the rainy day fund actually
investing right kind of saving is for
losers and investing is
uh how you build real wealth in the
country uh given in the uh the macro
environment that we live in
well it's true except saving savings is
often the only way while we're
incomposals
have because investing if you don't do
it carefully
it's very hard to do if you have
barriers by english by education
um and you can be very badly led astray
and of course even now in the zero
commission environment going into the
market
it's it's easier to do but there can be
tremendous risks because there's
investing
for the overnight types of gains we saw
in the game stock and we keep seeing
in some corners of the market and
that the old days you know people held
their stock it really is amazing
going back about 15 years most people
when they bought stock
in the markets they held on to it for at
least five years
now people sit by us are day trading and
going in and out of it minutes so it's
speculation in a lot of ways
not really long-term wealth accumulation
and i think
you know savings is really critical
so when you think about what's played
out over the last 12 months i want to
dig into kind of the federal reserve's
response right about
uh 13 or 12 months ago we saw
this public health crisis start to play
out um it led to
kind of mid-march of 2020 a massive
liquidity crisis
investors were selling every asset they
possibly could find to get dollars
uh asset prices sold off aggressively uh
and the federal reserve you know kind of
as predicted
uh had to step in and kind of save the
day in some way they've outlawed bear
markets and so when they stepped in
uh they went ahead and they started to
manipulate interest rates with the two
emergency rate cuts
and then they went ahead and started to
conduct quantitative easing in a
historic and
unprecedented way let's start just with
the initial action like what was your
take
uh about a year ago when they started to
be so aggressive in their response to
the public health crisis
i think the thing that stunned me the
most was the facilities the fed put
established because the last time the
fed looked at financial stability it
puts out a report
twice a year on how stable the u.s
financial system is
and it said he thought the financial
system was just fine was quite safe
because banks because of all the rules
after the last crisis banks were much
safer
and i long opposed i think it's fun the
banks should have the kinds of tough
rules they have
but when you have only one part of the
financial system heavily regulated
guess what money moves and other parts
of the
financial system that are unregulated
get much bigger
and in november when the fed said the
financial system looked great because
banks were so safe i
i said publicly at the time i don't
think so this is very asymmetric
and that's what happened in march of 20
of
2020 and if you look the fed not only
used its monetary policy tools
ultra low rates and quantitative easing
it's a big portfolio
but it's established a series of
facilities for the non-bank parts of the
sector
relying on banks to help the fed banks
became
agents of the fed and we bailed out
money market funds
we bailed out corporate bonds we bailed
out junk bonds
we bailed out hedge funds that's an
astonishing fact the fed did that in
2008 and promised it would never do it
again
and we clearly don't need financial
crises
but we don't need bailouts we got
bailouts
it feels like a lot of the bailouts too
went to uh the zombie companies right
companies that were just bad businesses
they were bad at capital allocators
and uh when you prevent the market
corrections from occurring
kind of the the bad businesses get to
stay in business for longer and so you
don't get the redistribution of those
resources whether they're
capital resources or intellectual
resources um and so is that a systemic
uh kind of risk moving forward is that
there's just a lot of these zombie
companies that are laden with debt
the government continues to bail them
out and it just creates a lot of
drag on the system absolutely and those
zombie companies are not hiring
typically they're using their low cost
debt
to pay back old debt and to reward
shareholders
investors private equity companies you
see zombie companies with tremendous
leverage
and they're using that money but they're
not using it for economic growth
when you bail out borrowers very high
risk borrowers you
who wouldn't it's in my business it's
called moral hazard because
you literally you can do anything and it
has no consequence
that's crazy absolute insanity um as we
continued to see the fed
through 2020 uh them and elected
officials
uh in uh cahoots with each other decided
that uh
their initial uh interest rate
manipulation down wasn't enough
uh the first kind of creation of money
through quantitative easing wasn't
enough
and then we saw just an onslaught in
markets whether it was through various
vehicles they set up
uh trillions and trillions of dollars uh
in quantitative easing
or the suppression of interest rates uh
for a prolonged period of time
and when all this was going on asset
prices took off
not only did they recover from the
drawdown uh but basically as
as the meme became stocks only go up
right every every asset only goes up uh
the crazy part is it seems like there's
truth to that given the macro
environment
given the monetary policy of course
they're only going to go up because the
fed is committed to continuing to
devalue and weaken the dollar
and so therefore asset prices are
essentially have to go up
uh across all asset classes not just
stocks is that kind of your read on the
situation
well i i don't think i would the fed is
not devaluing the dollar
i think there you have to look to fiscal
policy with our tremendous debt
uh the ultra low interest rates do have
an impact on the value of the dollar but
because the united states treasury was
still
the reserve currency in the world and
viewed as
quote flight to safety flight to quality
uh the fed has more scope than most
central banks to lower rates
where i really disagree with the fed is
that from 2010 to 2020
it bailed out the markets every time
markets got a little spooked by
efforts by the fed to normalize like to
maybe taper its portfolio or raise rates
a little bit
the feds stepped in there was something
called the taper tantrum in 2013 when
the fed said you know we
we don't want to have this huge
portfolio back then it was about i think
one and a half trillion dollars we think
we should get out of the market the bond
market which was being propped up
by the feds all those purchases said oh
no no the defensive oops sorry
even though the losses at that point
were very
relatively small and not in any way
systemic
the fed got spooked and then same thing
happened in 2018 the fed said raised
rates
just a little bit stock market went down
a bit
it corrected feds are oh we can't have
that
the fundamental mistake the fed has made
and that's why i think as i said it's
called i call it an engine of inequality
in my new book
is that it's confused financial markets
with the real economy
and it can prop financial markets up but
that does not mean
robust economic growth let alone shared
prosperity
it's got its eye on the wrong ball and
so when you think about the
spending uh and the debt uh one of the
most fascinating stats to me i think
since 2011 the federal income
revenue federal income tax revenue has
gone up every single year
right so we continue to collect more and
more federal income uh tax revenue
but also every single year from 2011
the inter year uh deficit continues to
get wider and wider and wider so it
seems like it's not a
revenue problem it's a spending problem
i think it's
both it's it's a spending problem and
it's combined by who pays the tax who
pays taxes
it's not just on the federal income tax
proportionally and this is in my book i
have a long discussion of exactly this
issue of who pays taxes
and poor people pay a lot more in taxes
than wealthy people we have a very
regressive tax system
so the more we spend the more the tax
burden goes up
on low moderate and middle-income
households
this is fiscal policy it's not the fed's
fault
but it is certainly a part of the
inequality equation
for sure and so the fed has now
committed to
uh higher levels of inflation for a
persistent amount of time right i think
when jerome powell
the chairman of federal reserve was
asked if they were thinking about
raising rates uh he literally said we
haven't even thought
about thinking about raising rates so
but you know there's no way that's
happening anytime soon according to them
uh but on top of that uh continued
quantitative easing and basically
pulling every lever they can
to get to those higher levels of
inflation uh one
do you think that that commitment is uh
genuine like are they actually going to
try to do it or is that more kind of lip
service of uh it sounds good but
actually they're not going to attempt to
to accomplish that
no they mean it they really do i i you
know i i think the fed
means well and it means what it says now
it may be called out
the bond market right now is pushing
inflation rates are going up outside the
fed and it may it may not be able to
honor its commitment
but it it it means what it said that it
will keep
rates as you say they won't even start
thinking about it until maybe 2023
i strongly disagree with that because if
the economy
takes back off in the second half of
this year we should normalize
the fed should not run every feature of
our economy
it's good at what it does but it's not
perfect
for sure and so when you think about um
kind of
if they're able to do it so they have a
commitment they're saying that they're
going to do it they want to do it let's
give them the benefit of the doubt and
say they're trying to do it
uh they have a limited set of tools in
order to accomplish higher levels of
inflation
uh there's one argument that says hey if
you print you know what
is going to end up being five plus
trillion dollars uh through quantitative
easing then
uh you're likely to get higher levels of
inflation we see
that people fear the inflation they're
moving capital and capitals flowing to
inflation hedge assets whether that's
real estate precious metals bitcoin etc
uh but also there's another argument a
pretty strong argument that no we are in
a deflationary environment technology is
deflationary and so
the federal reserve know how matter how
hard they try will
it will be nearly impossible for them to
actually accomplish higher levels of
inflation for a persistent amount of
time where do you come out on those two
schools of thought
the fed generally tries doesn't try to
to create inflation or deflation what it
does
is it tries to affect growth
and when you have a lot of and it's by
for example
stoking demand because if back in the
old days now
because america is now so unequal this
old theory doesn't work
part of the reason again the fed's an
engine of inequality
but if you lower rates so the thinking
goes at the fed
to say even below zero into on real
terms after taking inflation into
account what happens what's supposed to
happen is that people go out
borrow more money buy more stuff so
demand goes up
when demand goes up that does two things
it employment because people want more
stuff somebody's got to make
or sell or service the stuff and
demand for a limited supply of stuff
because supply will lag demand leads to
inflation
you know all of a sudden everybody wants
to take out a car loan goes gets a car
car prices go up and that's inflationary
so the fed tries to balance how much
borrowing it supports with ultra low
rates versus how much
demand it stokes that then results in
inflation
the problem again as my book really lays
out is that
because we're such an unequal country
higher income higher wealth
households they have all the stuff they
need so the fed can lower rates
as low as it wants they're not going to
go out buy another car or another house
they're going to do exactly what you
said anthony and invest
in the markets and some of them
investments will be in equities and some
of them will be
in more speculative assets like bitcoins
lower income people middle class people
already have more debt
and their debt costs them a lot more
than the low rates the fed charges
because the markets
often incorrectly think then risky
they may be buying stuff but they're
they're not generating growth
it's it's a very screwed up system
because again we're so
unequal and the fed is continuing to set
policy
as if we're the same united states we
were in 1975 we're not
for sure and so when you think about
this if you were uh
chairperson of the federal reserve
chairman of the
federal reserve what uh what would you
do what what what is kind of the
solution or what can they do
uh if you were in charge that uh that
you think could help remedy some of the
situations that they face
i think first thing is what i love the
office of federal reserve i think i
might
redecorate it a little bit
and if it's winter i'd light a gorgeous
great big fire
uh and then i'd get to work
and normalize i think and i know it's
not easy i think the fed should do
and my book has several fixes for the
fed and if i
were queen um i'd do them one
is i'd see america as it is
the federal reserve when they talk about
unemployment
they're only looking at one number that
misses many people who are under
were only working part-time who are
earning
low wages trying to get more wages
working more hours
their idea of what people who've left
the workforce
not because they don't want to work
because they've just given up
that's unemployment is very different
than the way the fed measures
net worth is very different the fed
looks at averages and says hey look
america is more wealthy
well the top one percent of the united
states in 2019
owns as much if not more wealth than the
bottom 50 percent
you can't look at averages you have to
look at distributional data
i do that to understand america as it is
then i would tell the markets
particularly
get ready we're going to normalize rates
will rise gradually
so that we give households a living
return on their savings accounts
that investors have safe assets and
other choices we're not all running
around
speculating in gamestop or bitcoins
people will put their money into assets
over the long term
because they get a living return and
then i would gradually and
but very significantly reduce the fed's
portfolio so that the economy isn't
always chasing the fed
the economy is working for
workers we're not doing that right now
yeah and it's very unfortunate what
would you say to people who
are middle class or uh live below the
poverty line
kind of anyone who's in that let's call
it you know bottom 60 percent of
americans either they own very very few
stocks or own no stocks or other
investable assets
what do they do what's kind of the best
thing that they can do in the given
environment that uh that we're living in
i'm not a household family financial
advisor i'm afraid that if i gave people
advice it would it would be wrong i do
think
it's really difficult watch your debt
and i know it's really hard to do
because
most people don't even have rainy day
funds forty percent of the united states
can't handle the equivalent of a of a
blown tire
so build in a small cushion even if
unfortunately
saving money doesn't reward you the way
it should
none of us can operate you know without
safeguards and i think
just as much as you can put some money
away
at the very least as a rainy day fund
for sure and so when you think about uh
kind of looking forward
what do you think happens right we
talked a little bit about what you would
do if you were in charge we talked about
what's already happened
how does this play out do we get the
higher levels of inflation and we get
everything kind of back to normal
is there some other scenario that you
see just like what's your kind of
prediction if you will
moving forward i work nights and
weekends to write my book i i didn't
need to write my book i have a
thriving company and a happy home life
and
lots of better things to do nights and
weekends than write
my book um but i think
if we don't reverse the engine of
of inequality so that the fed's role
in the future of american well is
better calibrated we're going to have
slow growth low inflation and
more and more inequality and you know
what that's going to mean more and more
anger we have seen a very angry country
the last
five six years and i one of the reasons
i wrote my book
i was thinking about these economic
equality issues and the role of monetary
policy
and then in 2015 2016
then we had the 2016 election and what i
saw then was that hillary clinton
took the fed's line the economy was in a
good place and millions of americans
didn't agree african americans stayed
home this isn't a good place for me
and millions of high school educated
white men came out and they voted for
donald trump he says
he said i'll make it a good place for
you i know you're suffering
he said that in lots of ways i didn't
agree with but he heard that
and we fought that out again in 2020
it's the very end let alone on january
6th this is an angry country and because
people don't think the system works for
them
and right now economically speaking it
doesn't
that we can fix the really important
thing about federal reserve policy is
that we don't need new law
we just need the fed to understand its
role
and revise it that that's among the
easiest solutions
i see in making america less unequal
sure and so when you think through this
um
it just feels like the world has shifted
uh psychologically and and people uh
believe that investable assets only go
up
uh it feels like the federal government
will step in
at any point and kind of address any
market correction
does this change the way that investors
allocate capital over a long period of
time or do you think that
uh there will be some sort of market
correction at some point
and we'll kind of get back to normal if
you want to put normal kind of an air
quotes in the sense of
uh i don't know what normal is anymore
but uh
is risk completely removed from the
market or is this just a temporary thing
over the last 12 months
oh and it's been it's not a temporary
thing we've had it since 2010
when the fed decided that it would
support the markets it was so
spooked by any instability in the
financial markets that it stepped in and
adjusted monetary policy
so we won't have normal until the fed
normalizes
takes its hand off the economy and lets
markets discipline themselves i mean why
wouldn't you speculate markets only the
markets indeed have always gone up
now can that last forever
i don't think it can because reality has
a nasty habit of catching up with all of
us you know
we can't we can't keep eating as much as
we want without something you know maybe
maybe there's magic food that doesn't
make us fat
but instead we just all have heart
attacks i mean it's just
discipline is always it's just if that's
somehow that's going to happen and if we
don't get it soon i think
market crashes will only continue to get
worse
i i tend to agree it's like uh the
analogy of uh we are addicted to
uh monetary intervention and monetary
stimulus the same way a drug dealer
or a drug addict is addicted to drugs
right you just got to get a bigger and
bigger hit to get the same high and
unfortunately it feels like that's where
we are right now i am afraid that's
right
but i think it can change again i wrote
my book
trying to lay out it's got solutions in
it we can change
i hope we do yeah um i'm there with you
and uh i was super excited to talk to
you because
uh there's not very many people who
understand that one of the greatest
causes of wealth inequality right now
uh literally is the very system that uh
we all rely on and uh it's unfortunate
it's sad
uh there's ways a week as people can
address it in terms of
getting people financially educated but
ultimately i think that there has to be
some systemic changes
and the way that we approach some of
this stuff to uh to help people just
feel like they are not constantly
falling behind
right it feels like it's a bigger and
bigger group of people who just
constantly feel like they can't fall
behind
and uh and they're upset they're angry
and frankly
uh they're in a position where they're
uh fairly helpless which is uh
not a position i think that the greatest
country in the world wants to be it
oh no absolutely not all right i got
three questions for you to finish up and
then you get to ask me one
uh to end us the first is what is the
most important book you've ever read
now you warned me about this i've been
mut
the equivalent of muttering in my brain
and obviously other than
you know the big books like the bible
which
has helped to guide me through my life i
think
i would say war and peace by leo tolstoy
i have actually read it um
alone and then with a group of my
friends in a reading group uh
three or four times and i always get
more out of it each time as a guide to
thinking about
our lives and the role we each play in
history
it's it's a really profound book as well
as quite a good read
i love that suggestion that's a great
suggestion second question
sleep schedule i used to sleep five or
six hours now i sleep eight or nine our
good friends over at eight sleep
uh they are the ones who convinced me to
sleep on this thermo-regulated bed
basically i make it freezing cold
and fall asleep like a little baby uh
and have a completely changed my life
what uh what's your sleep schedule and
how has that evolved over the years
i don't i don't have anything fancy
um i have a um i'm blind so i have a
guide dog who i need
to get out uh particularly on days when
i'm just spending all my time
um typing and talking which he thinks is
just
really boring
what are we going to do so my husband
and i tried
very hard to get out first thing in the
morning
and um walk um three four miles
uh and we live very close to a beautiful
park in washington dc and
we try to get out there at sunrise and
then that makes it
really easy to get to sleep at night so
it's it's old school
absolutely i love that uh last question
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
i am a um open to suggestion
i do think it's hard to believe given
what i know about people as i've gotten
older that if we're the best god could
do for the universe
that's a very sorry thing to expect i i
hope there
i hope there are others and i hope we
can we can find them and they can they
can help make us better
i i tend to think that there's
intellectual life somewhere
uh or intelligent life somewhere but uh
we are unlikely to come in contact with
them
over uh any for any sort of uh time
frame where you or i are alive
unfortunately
that's why i keep my focus on things i
can try to do something about like the
fed that you know we can
we can put the engine of inequality into
into even
a slow reverse that would be really
worthwhile
absolutely you get to ask me one
question to finish up what do you got
for me
i think when you're in you're in miami
now anthony you tell me
how are you seeing the economic
inequality play out
in that city you know it's a real city
where there are
very wealthy people living down on you
know in the ocean
and large amounts of immigrants what's
it like
so i'll speak more to new york uh where
where i spent most of uh the pandemic
more so than miami
uh and mainly because it's more
egregious there
right so miami basically uh you know
they still believe in american freedom
and
uh they've got restaurants bars uh
businesses
are open you have to be smart in terms
of the virus and you know wear masks and
social distance and kind of all the
things that we know are
are positive but in new york uh they
basically shut everything down
and so i remember uh literally there was
one day during the pandemic
i spoke to a friend of mine he's
incredibly wealthy he's done very very
well for himself financially over the
years
and uh the conversation was he was
basically trying to figure out how he
could time the market so that he could
buy
a much bigger place in new york city
even though he lives in london
and uh he was watching the real estate
prices crash and he was there with a
bunch of cash and he was going to go in
and kind of
you know jump on the opportunity to to
do an all-cash offer and he was going to
make out like a bandit
and so that you know kind of a financial
conversation with a very very wealthy
person
that night i went to dinner with my wife
at a restaurant down the street and we
kept going to this one place because
it's a small little hole in the wall
spanish place
and the restaurant tour told me that he
was struggling he was struggling bad and
i asked him you know
what do you mean and he said uh every
day for lunch it's near the un building
he said i used to have 80
tables right meaning that i would flip
the tables over in terms of
throughput and so i would serve 80 meals
at those tables during lunch she goes
now i do
six oh and so what you realized was
he probably was actually pretty lucky
it's him his brother and he's got one
employee
he cooks the food he helps do service
like it's a it's very much a family
owned
type business with not a large staff and
so
uh his cost structure is relatively uh
consistent but when you get that
pressure you can see this guy is
probably not going to make it he's doing
the best he absolutely can to try to
make it
but the the dissonance between a
conversation with uh somebody who was
incredibly wealthy who was basically
you know looking to capitalize on the
opportunity not because they're
greedy not because they are a malicious
or nefarious person but just because
they have the wealth to do it right and
so buy things at a low price and sell
them at a high price like that is how
you make money and
this person was well versed in that but
comparing that to a restaurateur who you
know
really really was in trouble uh i think
it just struck me like
there's two worlds right now right two
americas if you will and i think that
that is
uh unfortunately just playing out in
cities around the
country um and hopefully that'll you
know kind of get mitigated here quickly
and we can kind of get back to
uh as close to full employment as we can
and and we can start to get back in a
better environment but it's definitely
not a good situation
when you see that type of stuff
happening
now i hope so too absolutely all right
karen where can we send people to find
you on the internet find the book
or find more about your other work um
you can find it
by the book is called an engine of
inequality the fed and the future of
wealth in america
you can find it on any of the bookstore
sites
um amazon barnes and noble on the web
um you can uh google me and
go to my company's website we have a
book page
um and um i think it it's gonna be i'm
pretty easy to find
yes you are listen i really really
appreciate all your time today this was
a lot of fun for me i think that
you were way ahead of the curve on a lot
of this stuff and hopefully people
learned a ton today they'll go read the
book
and we'll have to just get in the future
thank you so much anthony i really
enjoyed this